لا تزال روسيا تمر بصدمه وغضب كبيرين عدى
عن سيل واسع من الانتقادات اثراء ضربه
مكيفك ليله راس السنه هجوم صاروخيه على
معسكر تابع للقوات الروسيه يقع في مخيف
كبير اوكرانيا نفذ باستخدام انظمه صواريخ
هاي مارس التي حصلت عليها اوكرانيا من
الولايات المتحده وفق اعلان الجيش الروسي
الهجوم اسفر عن حصيله من القتل ارتفعت الى
90 جنديه الروسيه بعد العثور على المزيد
من الجثث تحت الانقاذ وفق اعلان نادر من
القوه الروسيه والحصله مرشحه للزياده
موسكو الغاضبه قالت ان تحقيقات ذكرت ان
السبب الرئيس هو ان العسكريين شغله
واستخدموا على نطاق واسع هواتفهم المحموله
في منطقه تطالها اسلحه العدو بما يتعارض
مع حضر استعمالها ومن ثم نجحت القوه
الاوكرانيه في رصدهم واستهدافهم الاعلان
عن هذه الحص اثار انتقادات جديده للقياده
العسكريه الروسيه على عدم كفاءتها على
لسان المراسلين الحربيين والمعلقين الروس
كونه يتزامن مع سلسله من الانتكاسات
العسكريه المحرجه التي منيت بها القوات
الروسيه في الاشهر الاخيره بالمقابل اكدت
هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه انها نفذت
هذه الضربه واعلن قسم الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في الجيش الاوكرانيه ان
الحصيله اكبر مما اعلن عنه في صفوف الروس
وتصل الى حوالي 400 قتيل واصابه 300 جندي
روسي اخرين
ميسي
حقيقي
من قبل افراد الفوج للهواتف المحموله ما
جعلهم في متناول اسلحه العدو وسبح هذا
للعدو بتحديد احداثيات مواقع الافراج
العسكريين لشن الضربه الصاروخيه يتم حاليا
اذا السيسي
[موسيقى]
هناك سؤال موضوع من موسكو مع
المحلل العسكري
ومنكياف معنى الدكتور الكسندر بوغومولوف
مدير المعهد الوطني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
مرحبا بكم الكريمين
معك الجنود الروس فتحوا هواتفهم ليله راس
السنه واين في ميدان حرب في معركه وهم
يعلمون جيدا انه يمكن تحديد مواقع هم وهذا
ما حصل وفي اكبر يعني ضربه موجعه لروسيا
مع بدايات هذه السنه من يتحمل المسؤوليه
هذا الخطا هل هو ضعف لدى القاده الروس عدم
انضباط من قبل الجنود اما ماذا بالتحديد
تحيه طيبه
بالفعل تفاجئنا جدا في هذا الخبر الاسود
عندما
نتيجه الضربه الصاروخيه
في منتصف الليل على عيد راس السنه
استشهد هناك
عدد كبير من المقاتلين الروس مراتب وجنود
والضباط كانت هناك الحصيله الاوليه 63 من
ثم يرتفعت الحصري الى نحو 90 ولا اعتقد
هذا هي الحصيله النهائيه تبع همم
معلومات الوالده الملكيه همم مقتل 4
جناحه ب 300 هذا خارج المنطقه وخارج
الكلام لا يريد وناقشه اطلاقا ولكن اذا
رجعنا الى سور بالصور ما هو السبب ف- همم
طبعا همم الكلام همم الرسمي على لسان ضربه
رفع المستوى روسي رتبته همم فريق وهو يشغل
منصب النائب الاول لمدير هيئه التوجيه
المعنوي همم الذي قال ان السبب يعود الى
تشغيل الهواتف الخلويه بان واحد هذا كلام
غير مقنع لان همم الضربه صارت في همم بعد
دقيقه واحده فقط بعد منتصف الليل يعني
دقيقه واحده هذا وقت غير كافي لالتقاط
الاحداثيات وذكر المعلومات
فتح الهواتف من قبل الجنود ليست هي السبب
الحقيقي همم
امر عسكري تم صدوره قبل فتره في
استهلاك استهلاك او استخدام الهواتف
المحموله في خط الجبهه هذا امر من من من
من همم
تنفيذه بدون اي مناقشه
علما بان يمكن التقاط احداثيات الهاتف همم
ليس في وقت استعماله فحسب بل حتى ان كان
الهاتف هذا مغلقا
الاهدافيات يمكن التقاطها بكل سهوله همم
السبب الحقيقي براي يعود الى القرار الذي
تم اتخاذه من قبل
عسكري همم الى هذه الوحده
لاحتلال هذه المدرسه المهنيه في مدينه همم
وكيف كده همم امره والامر توجيه توجيه
والجنود راحوا احتلوا هذا المكان اكثر من
ذلك نفس نفس البنايه كان فيها مستودع
الزخيره للذخيره نعم
هممليات العسكريه يعني
الخاطئ هذا هو السبب همم
ان يكون موقع المدرسه التي كان موجود فيها
الجنود يعني هو قريب من من الجنود
الاوكرانيين ام ماذا تقصد يعني هذا هو
القرار الخاطئ هذا احد الاوامر وانه هناك
في مخزن للذخيره وبالتالي عندما سقطت
الصواريخ ادى الى انفجار هائل وادى الى
عدد كبير من القتل في صفوف الجنود الروسي
وصلت الفكره ولكن دعني اخذ راي ضيفي من
كيف الدكتور اوف دكتور ما رايك هل يعني
المساله تنم على همم خلل ربما او عدم
انضباط في همم لدى الجيش الروسي ام لا
هناك من يرى انه الاوكرانيون حصلوا على
التكنولوجيات متطوره من قبل الامريكيين
تحديدا مكانتهم من القدره الالكترونيه على
تحديد مواقع الجنود الروس وكذلك صواريخ
هاي مارس هي التي صنعت هذا الفرق هل تعتقد
ان هذه هي
باب وراء هذه الحصيله الثقيله همم في لدى
الجنود الروس في هذه الضربه الاوكرانيه في
مكيف كان ليله راس السنه
اولى من قبل كل شيء يعني اعل ظواهر عن
نناقش خليه يعني عن نشاهد هذه الظواهر
باستمرار يعني من اول يوم الحربي يعني
بالنسبه للاستعمال الهاتفات يعني بدل من
الراديوهات العسكريه فهو باستمرار حاصل
يعني من اول يوم الحرب ولذلك استبيل مثال
همم
القوات التي حاولت ان تقتحم مدينه او تحت
مدينه في العاصمه يعني هي عملت نفسه شيء
يعني وتعرضت على نفس الضربات يعني حتى بعد
عدم وجود غيمرس يعني اللي هي صحيح انه
سلاح متطور امريكي
اصبح متوفر يعني مؤخرا وليس من بدايه
الحرب
بوجود بالنسبه
همم ظاهره منتشره يعني معروفه من اول يوم
الحرب يعني كذلك همم يعني الحروب حاليا
يعني اهم شيء في الحروب ليس حتى القدره
القتاليه انما القدره للوجستيه
ضعف اللوجستيو الروسي واضح باستمرار وكذلك
عدم عدم قدراتهم على تعلم حتى من الاخطاء
يعني همم لماذا همم اليوم همم يعني جوني
بطل الانذار يعني كلها الى هذه الحادث
فعلا فعلا كبير
يعني انت لا ترجع السبب الى التفوق
العسكري ربما الاوكراني الذي حصلت عليه من
امريكا بل بسبب انخفاض معنويه الجنود
الروسي طيب مثل اخرى عن الحصيله طيب
همم شاكوش
بالنسبه همم القدره
دكتور بوغا مول اوف ضيفي من موسكو كان همم
اشار الى مساله هامه مساله عدد ضحايا
روسيا اعلنت ان العدد ارتفع الى 90 قتيل
في صفوفها واعتراف نادر من روسي ان تعترف
بسقوط ضحايا بينما الاوكرانيون يتحدثون عن
400 قتيل همم هل لديكم ما يؤكد ذلك هذا
العدد الكبير من القتلى 400 جندي روسي جدا
بسيط يعني عندك يعني ما عمل صوره صوره
المبنى لو كان هناك 90 يعني فهنا هناك حتى
ولا جناح واحد من المبنى المبنى اكبر
بالكثير المبنى ممكن يستحمل وجود تقريبا
همم 5% سرير اقل شيء يعني اذا كان هو
يستعمل
الجن الجنود يعني همم المبنى ثلاثه
يعني على كل طابق هناك اكثر يعني تقريبا
اقل شيء 10 غرف كبيره غرف دراسه لان هي
مبنى مدرسه فنيه هناك مجال واسعه جدا لو
كان فعلا 90 فلا يباله لانه 90 ضحايا بدفع
واحده عم يحصل كل يوم يعني
هذا ضربات تعتبر يعني اعتياديه
الجانب الروسي لا يهتم يعني حتى ولا يعلق
على الناس هذه الاحداث همم سيد همم المبنى
الذي استهدف في مكه كما قال ضيفه يعني
يتسع ل 500 سرير وبالتالي الحصيله ال 400
جندي روسي التي يتحدث عن الاوكرانيون تبدو
منطقيه ما رايك
انا لا يعني
احصائيات الاوكرانيه اطلاقا لانه كثيرا ما
كانت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه وحتى رئاسه
جمهوريه تقول انها
قوات الدفاع الجوي الاكرانيه تمكنت
120% من الصواريخ الروسيه التي تم اسقاطها
يعني اسقطه اكثر من من كان ايطاليا
غريبه
لا يمكن اعتبار
طيب ساعود اليك في كيف لي لترد كذلك ولكن
اريد ان اسالك كذلك سيد شاشكوف مساله اخرى
قرات عنها قيل انه ال ال الجنود الذين تم
الذين فقدوا حياتهم في في هذه الضربه
غالبيتهم من التعبئه الاخيره التي اعلنها
الرئيس فلدينمر بوتين الى اي حد هذا يطرح
كذلك تساؤلنا على مساله الخبره العسكريه
لانه هذا جنود يعني ليست لديهم خبره
عسكريه كبيره هم التحقوا بعد همم طلب
التعب الذي اعلنه الرئيس
هل هناك مشكله في جنود الاحتياط
بالفعل
الاغلبيه من
هؤلاء الذين استشهدوا في هذه الضربه
كانوا من المجندين الجدد نتيجه التعبئه
الاخيره ولكن نتابع الاخير
ليست يعني ااا ليست لهم اي خبره العسكريه
اطلاقا لانه قرار التابع كان يقول لا يجوز
تعبئه هؤلاء الذين لا يخدموا في الجيش
سابقا اذا الموضوع هو موضوع الارتياح لانه
البعد منهم همم حسبوا ربما حاسبه انه مكيف
بعيد عن خط الجبهه وهم في منطقه امنه همم
يحتفلون بعيد الاستثناء والاخره يعني كان
هناك نوع من الاسترخاء نفسه وهذا ايضا
كبير همم على القياده العسكريه القياده
العسكريه التي لما همم تبذل كود جهودهم
همم على
رفع اليقظه اليقظه هذا عامل مؤثر جدا طيب
همم دكتور اليكساندر في كيف همم يعني صحيح
هي ضربه قويه من قبل الجيش الاوكراني ضد
الجيش الروسي في المعركه ولكن هناك من
يحذر من غضب روسيا وبلاضي من بوتين خاصه
في ظل مشاهد الامهات والارامل الذين فقدوا
ازواجهم وابنائهم الذين قتلوا في مكيفك
هناك من يتخوف من رد روسيا مزلزل ضد همم
اوكرانيا همم ماذا تتوقعون شكل الرد
الروسي على هذه الضربه الموجعه في مكه
بمناسبه راس السنه ضربت الروسي يعني ولا
البنيه التحتيه لمدنيه وكذلك المباني
والمباني والسكن هناك عشرات من
الاوكرانيين المدنيين استشهدوا يعني قبل
يومين او ثلاثه ايام يعني فماذا هذا
الحديث يعني ماذا
بصراحه
ذول الناس يعني كومبات يعني هم جنود يعني
وافقوا على ان يكون الجنود يعني فهو من
راحوا للغرب
همم منطبق تماما بعرائها في الحرب اما ما
فعلت روسيا وعام تفعل كل يوم باستمرار وهو
مخالف الاعراف وقوانين الحرب وباستمرار
ومصر على هذا على هذه التكتيكات يعني
التكتيكات التي تهدف تهدف المدنيين يعني
بالذات يعني وليس العسكريين فماذا نقول
بعد ذلك ماذا ماذا ماذا
ننتظر من
نصيحه سيد شاشكو في موسكو الى اين يمكن ان
يصل الرد الروسي
همم
[موسيقى]
بدون
الحادثه الماساوي الدمويه والمؤلمه
لا اعتقد انه سوف تريد روسيا همم
[موسيقى]
الانتقام الموضوع اكبر واوسع من الانتقام
الموضوع هو تحقيق الهدف الرئيسي لهذه
العمليه حتى ولو لم تعترف همم
الاداره الروسيه
بانها الحرب وهي الحرب في الحقيقه انه همم
العمليات العسكريه التي تشترك فيها كل
ظروف ولا اسلحه وحتى همم
الكبير جدا من الخسائر في الارواح
والمعدات
فالموضوع اوسع همم نعم هذا هو الدرس
الدفاعات روسيه بالدم هذا الدرس الذي لا
يجب استعابه وعدم تكراره
والعماليه سوف تستغرق والحرب هذه سوف
تتواصل الى تحقيق اهداف ورده دعواتك الجيش
والقوات المسلحه
مدير المعهد الوطني للدراسات الاستراتي